i will now officially welcome you as the
newest of more than 100,000 global
alumni of carnegie mellon university you
have much to be proud of today is as
much about looking ahead as it is
looking back as you anticipate your next
endeavor I would like to encourage you
to do so confident in the knowledge that
CMU has equipped you for whatever comes
next and in ways that are totally
unpredictable today that you might not
might not even recognize you already
know that you have been deeply educated
in your major field of study employers
around the world tell us consistently
that CMU graduates are exceptionally
well prepared to contribute to their
organizations from day one you know how
to conceptualize a complex problem frame
a novel interpretation show
extraordinary artistic talent and work
effectively on Team the content
knowledge you acquired here will almost
certainly require a newer but the
conceptual foundations you have
established will allow you to continue
to learn over the course of your lives
but I want to suggest that you have also
been learning other lessons both inside
and outside the formal curriculum you've
been immersed in an environment that
drives on innovation collaboration
collegiality and a creative response to
the unexpected you learn to invent new
things to work with others on a club
activity a buggy team on a community
project you learn to
municate with people who are different
in background and style of working these
are critical skills for the future and
the world where the momentum of
innovation will only accelerate none of
us can predict how these threads will
intertwine through our lives small
moments can circle back in our lives in
ways that are totally unforeseen you
cannot imagine them today let me give
you a few examples on the twenty-fourth
of August 1977 I took my maiden flight
traveled over several thousand miles and
landed in Ames Iowa for a graduate study
in mechanical engineering at Iowa State
University a step that will permanently
force me to speak with an Iowa accent I
turned on my within a few days of
arriving I turned on my first American
TV most of you will not know what it was
like small vacuum tube black and white
and what was on the very first image I
saw on my first American television was
the image of Hawkeye Pierce from the
sitcom mash starring Alan Alda at that
moment I would never ever have believed
that I would meet this world famous
actor or have the opportunity it is to
discuss science literacy with him at the
National Science Foundation let alone
award him an honorary degree right here
at Carnegie Mellon University
traveling to Iowa State University for
me was only possible because i received
a travel grant from a trust established
by the indian major industrial
conglomerate taught us two years ago on
this very stage mr. Ratan Tata received
an honorary degree and I met him here at
Carnegie Mellon University how could I
have ever known in 1977 that this will
be the path i will take none of us can
predict the trajectory of our lives and
careers called women who grew up in
rural Oregon who received an honorary
degree today struggled to get even to a
library close to the house that he lived
in which was hundred miles away more
than 50 of 50 of those miles were on
unpaved roads winning a nobel prize in
physics was not even in his universe of
imagined possibilities yet he did win a
Nobel price in 2001 for his pioneering
discoveries related to the bose-einstein
condensate
called beautifully complements that
profound accomplishment with a deep
empathy here's today for students
struggling to learn science in 1967
right here on our own campus a young
undergraduate junior wrote a musical
written by a fellow student wrote a
musical for scotch and Soda performed by
fellow students that was Stephen
Schwartz the show he called Pippin
became a major sensation and remains one
of the biggest Broadway hits of our time
nearly 50 years after its CMU premiere
I could tell similar stories about many
of the people sitting behind me on the
stage many of the people on whom we have
bestowed honorary degrees life did not
unfold according to any precise plan but
these success stories are built upon the
ability to bring to each new
circumstance once individual strengths
purpose passion and principles these are
innovators able to pivot Perry and adopt
the unexpected and they responded aspect
from their hearts as from their heads
this will be true in your life's to as
the strands of your lives unfold and
intertwine things will arise that you
did not and could not predict or plan
for that's okay your generation has
lived with almost non-stop change for
your entire lives you simply expect that
new ideas new tools and new devices will
emerge continually and that
long-established truths and practices
could be and would be discarded you are
innovators on a scale unprecedented in
human history this is just normal life
for you this explosion of knowledge has
come about at least in part because many
disciplines are coming together more
readily than ever before abetted by
technologies of discovery and new
sources of data the confluence of
biology behavioral sciences and
computation underpin advances in brain
science progress in energy and
sustainability requires engineers of
every sort plus economists architects
designers policy analyst historians and
computer scientists the fine and
Performing Arts are continually engaged
with science and technology
both as new expressive media and as
sources of artistic themes and concerns
no matter what you failed is you have
already come to appreciate the creative
clash of disciplines that is something
that Carnegie Mellon is very well known
for as we look at the 21st century ahead
of you I kind of all of us one of the
most defining characteristics of the
21st century is the way in which
technology impacts human condition no
other university can prepare its
graduates at the intersections of
technology and human condition as
Carnegie Mellon can Alan Alda has the
rare and probably even unique
distinction of being named for an Oscar
an Emmy and a Tony as well as a best
best-selling book all in the same year
an incredible achievement but with the
expansion and intricate connection of
areas of inquiry new and even more
amazing possibilities will emerge
someday we could have the possibility
that there will be somebody who is
nominated for an Oscar an Emmy a Tony
the best-selling book a Turing award in
computer science and the Nobel Prize all
in the same year and that's likely to
happen at Carnegie Mellon
the ability to respond productively to
unanticipated outcomes to be open to
innovative ideas and to grow your
capacity to work across diverse fields
with diverse others while keeping your
hearts and the work and having your work
come from your heart and connecting to
the work that is in your hearts these
brought you here today they will be even
more important for your future and I am
very confident view that you are
perfectly ready today and we your
families your professors your mentors
and carnegie mellon university look
forward to seeing you seeing the impact
of the class of 2015 around the world we
want to support and celebrate you every
step of your way so my final request to
you today is to stay in touch be
connected with Carnegie Mellon
University forever stay involved take
advantage of the CMU alumni network
connect to one another if the 115 year
history of Carnegie Mellon University is
any indication those of you sitting here
receiving your degrees today will be
movers shakers leaders innovators
extraordinary artists humanists social
scientists designers so there is a piece
of practical advice when you look to the
person sitting in front of you next to
you are behind you remember 20 30 years
from now there'll be leaders they will
have a lot of resources some of them may
be your boss be nice to them
it will come in handy keep in touch with
them with together with them you will
change the world my warmest
congratulations and best wishes to each
and every one of you congratulations
we